merci bonsoir à tous j'espère que vous
passez une bonne soirée je commencer
d'abord par vous félicite et je vais
vous dire pourquoi il ya une bonne
raison
on vit dans un temps où le cynisme a
atteint une telle apogée ou la distance
entre les genres a atteint une un tel
niveau où le défaitisme la tristesse du
processus de déshumanisation soit un tel
point que vivre ensemble est devenu un
acte militant et vous prouver le
contraire exactement ce soir vivre
ensemble
mathématiquement c'est penser c'est
croire que notre union est plus grande
que notre sol c'est penser qu'on a plus
de choses à faire ensemble et qu'on
s'enrichit les uns les autres de nos
différences mutuel de nos parcours
mutuel de nos compétences de nos talents
de nos inspirations mutuelle quand on
interroge les gens sur leur parcours de
vie
il ya une question que j'aimerais vous
poser c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut
être bien avec les autres lorsqu'on
n'est pas bien avec soi-même
comment est ce qu'on peut faire société
comment est ce qu'on peut vivre ensemble
quand on n'est pas serein et quand on
n'est pas apaisée avec nos propres choix
avec nos propres parcours
cette notion de choix
c'est l'idée centrale que j'aimerais été
pendant le temps de mon intervention
quand on interroge les gens sur la
manière dont ils ont pris leur décision
la manière dont ils perçoivent leur vie
rétrospectivement et à cette idée qui
est parfaitement synthétisé dans le
titre de l'autobiographie d'un auteur
égyptien et ce titre c'est l'histoire
que je porte sur le dos je suis
l'histoire que je porte sur le dos en
d'autres termes je suis et je porte ce
que j'ai vécu je suis le fruit de mes
choix parfois des choix des autres
souvent et on voit que l'ensemble de ses
choix
l'interaction de ces choix produit mon
histoire et cette histoire parfois les
lourds
porter parfois alain fabre du mans c'est
la manière dont elle va être verbalisés
et cette manière de voir l'histoire les
choix
la manière dont on se positionne c'est
cohérent avec ce que l'on sait du temps
du sens de l'écoulement du temps la
manière dont on a été éduqué aussi est
passée précède le présent le présent
précède le futur les choix d'hier sont
les conséquences d'aujourd'hui et les
choix d'aujourd'hui produisent les
conséquences de demain et dans cette
idée là dans ce sens là on a quelque
chose qui est très fort et qui consiste
à dire que on vire marche avant passé
présent futur mais on pense en marche
arrière
c'est à dire que l'on se réfère à des
expériences passées à des anecdotes
passer à des événements passés pour
essayer de déduire du sens ce même sens
qui va guider nos choix et là il ya une
dualité
il ya à la fois l'idée d'un héritage
il ya à la fois l'idée d'un déterminisme
un héritage d'abord parce qu'en tant
qu'être humain nous vivons ensemble et
donc nous transmettons continuellement
des idées des messages des sentiments
des émotions parfois d'une extrême
intensité dans le bon comme dans le
mauvais sens du terme et cette
transparence est transmission temporel
parlons c'est le sens et la définition
même de l'héritage est la deuxième
motion c'est celle de déterminisme le
déterminisme c'est la puissance du récit
passer sur nos choix et sur nos vies
d'accord ce déterminisme il peut tenir à
nos parcours familiaux à notre identité
religieuse ou culturelle
parfois les tno culturel d'accord et on
a tendance à essayer de chercher des
occurrences et à reproduire des
occurrences de succès si on a vu ou si
on a vécu des choses qui ont été
couronnés de succès on a envie de les
reproduire
si on a vu des échecs et des souffrances
on a envie de
évitez est donc serré 6 passes et
conditionne la manière dont on
appréhende nos choix nos choix présent
et ce déterminisme là sociologiquement
et produire un certain nombre de
réalités
il explique que un certain nombre
d'élites se reproduise elles sont
stables quasiment stable
sociologiquement et donc elles ont
tendance à préserver protéger reproduire
répétées des réalités sociales et puis
pour d'autres communautés ou groupes
socio économiques qui sont maintenus
dans une certaines conditions on a
l'impression que quand quelqu'un change
sa condition place dans le groupe à
l'autre va évoluer vers plus de bonheur
plus d'éducation plus d'accès plus de
choix plus de pouvoir parfois
socio-économique dans l'impression que
c'est un récit individuel c'est une
performance individuelle c'est la
capacité d'un individu a cassé le
plafond de verre a dépassé le
déterminisme de son groupe et ça c'est
une tragédie pourquoi pas ce que ça veut
dire que des réussites individuelles
masque souvent d échec collectif
sur le plan politique
quand on y pense le conservatisme n'est
rien d'autre que cette préférence pour
le passé pour la volonté de maintenir un
certain état des choses dans mon monde à
moi dans le monde des probabilités et
des statistiques toutes sortes de
questions
alors je vous rassure on va pas faire
des mathématiques avec des formules et
je vais vous passez les équations sauf
s'ils ont passé un test pour les
étudiantes qui sont elles qui sont ici
mais je vais vous expliquer à quel point
nous êtres humains on est pas ou peu ou
mal équipé pour raisonner avec les
probabilités
je vous donnais juste quelques exemples
avant de poursuivre mon raisonnement
quand il ya eu la crise financière il ya
quelques années on a eu un certain
nombre d'experts expert c'est un titre
sans diplôme marie sur un plateau télé
on a non et puis juste en dessous on a
experts en finance expert en logique des
marchés experts mathématiques
financières et ce titre d'accord il
confère une espèce d'autorité d'accord
et ses experts donc les mêmes qui
deux minutes avant le crash financier
étaient incapables de produire une
analyse ou de prédire ou d'expliquer ou
de mettre en garde contre les dangers
systémique dans lesquels on était et
bien ces mêmes experts la seconde
suivante se retrouver investi d'une
espèce de révélations à savoir la
capacité d'analysé à dire voilà on sait
exactement pourquoi ça s'est produit
voilà pourquoi ça s'est passé comme ceux
ci et on le savait on le voyait venir
depuis des années et c'était obligé
qu'on arrive dans cette séquence là
pourtant trois secondes auparavant passé
présent futur
j'étais incapable de le prédire donc le
même degré de certitude qu'ils ont a
posteriori dans l'événement est
directement symétrique au degré
d'ignorance totale dans le tennis était
avant l'événement la certitude et la
crédibilité que l'on attribue à ses
discours d' expertise elle vous montre à
quel point au bout du compte en tant que
citoyen en tant que consommateurs
parfois on est soit crédules soit soumis
un certain nombre de règles un certain
nombre de cadres formels qui signale une
expertise qui signale l'autorité et ces
choix là ses certitudes et ses erreurs
on se les applique à nous mêmes sommes
dans nos décisions au quotidien vous
voyez par exemple quelque chose qui est
très répandue c'est l'aversion au risque
en langage comment ça veut dire que au
bout du compte on se sent mieux avec la
certitude d'avoir fait une erreur
qu'avec une chance sur deux d'avoir
raison on vit très mal créée de manière
quasi physiologique
l'idée de ne pas savoir je ne sais pas
ce qui se passe je vous le voyez quand
on va à la mer ou que l'eau est trouble
vous il ya un requin n'y a pas un requin
ce qui se passe
je préfère savoir qu'il ya un requin au
moins c'est dit c'est dit c'est dit
d'accord je vois la chrage plutôt de me
dire il ya en dessous je sais pas où il
est qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
peut-être même en plancton g les shadoks
ont formulé cela parfaitement
mieux vaut continuer à pomper et qui ne
se passe rien plutôt que d'arrêter de
pompey est de courir le risque qu'il se
passe quelque chose donc nouveau faire
quelque chose dont on sait pertinemment
que c'est totalement inutile voire même
épuisant voire même dommageable
d'accord on l'a vu tout à l'heure on
peut comprendre que ça a des
conséquences sur la nature d'accord
plutôt de prendre le risque d'essayer
autre chose et qu'il se passe quelque
chose de positif
d'accord ça c'est une aversion au risque
direct mais ça signale verbalement une
en sécurité chez psychologiquement même
physiologique avec le fait d'être dans
une logique dans certains et même chose
pour nos choix donc pour essayer de
restituer la logique ou vie en marche
avant et on pense en marche arrière en
mathématiques pour essayer de prédire et
d'évaluer des phénomènes financier
météorologiques ou autre on a des
techniques
l'une d'entre elles elle s'appelle la
technique de monte carlo après le nom
d'une ville où apparemment il ya
beaucoup de casino et il consiste à
faire des simulations
donc on simule on peut simuler des
actifs financiers
on peut simuler la température d'un
bassin on peut simuler le nombre
d'allers et venues dans une gare à une
heure donnée de la journée d'accord et
on définit juste une variable et cette
variable à tout instant elle est définit
par deux choses assez des simulations de
monte carlo je vais vous expliquer dans
une seconde comment ça fonctionne
donc n'ayez pas peur c'est juste une
espèce de damas de couleur on est
toujours dans la pédagogie montessori
donc on se laisse aller on va vers la
découverte
donc je disais que à tout moment la
variable est déterminé par deux choses
si je prends cette trajectoire allant
par exemple la petite verte qui roule
c'est un chemin possible une trajectoire
possible
possible et quand je me situe à ce point
ci par exemple main variable elle est
définit par deux choses la première
c'est son historique c'est-à-dire toute
la partie qui précède dans le temps
depuis l'origine et la deuxième chose
c'est son mouvement instantanée sa
dynamique du moment
si on était des êtres humains notre état
d'esprit et notre choix du moment
d'accord et donc l'information total
c'est l'ensemble des trajectoires à un
moment donné c'est l'ensemble des
trajectoires passer si je me situe à la
date sans au 100e jour par exemple
l'information passé elle est concentrée
par la somme on parle par l'analyse
conjointe de toutes ces trajectoires et
puis ensuite je continue certaines de
ces trajectoires vont être considéré
comme couronnée de succès d'autres vont
être considérée peut-être comme un héros
comme un échec mais on voit que à tout
moment c'est l'histoire passée qui
définit la manière dont je constitue
l'information dont je conçois une
analyse la question c'est est ce qu'il
existe une autre façon de voir le monde
parce que là on a l'impression que je
vis en marché avant je pense en marche
arrière et il a quelque chose qui tient
aux décalages et qui fait qu'il ya une
insécurité dans ce chemin là puisque
c'est le passé qui nous donnent toute
leur formation
le déterminisme est à son maximum
puisque à part mon état d'esprit
instantanée je suis la somme de cette
vie passée
je suis la somme de ses expériences
passées donc pour ceux d'entre nous qui
sont un peu familier avec les maths ou
qui sont allés jusqu à la résolution de
problèmes au minimum pour un même
problème il existe parfois plusieurs
solutions et donc pour ce problème là il
existe plusieurs façons et plusieurs
approches différentes
l'une d'entre elles consiste à dire en
fait et si on retournait notre modèle et
si on veut tourner notre monde et si on
mettait notre monde à l'envers pour le
remettre à l'endroit
et je vais vous expliquer comment cette
méthode on appelle la méthode des arbres
elle voit le monde futur comme une
arborescence qui découle des choix que
nous faisons en l'instant main à
l'instant même
à cet instant précis et donc on peut
avoir des arbres binôme you ils ont deux
branches des arbres trinôme you ils ont
trois branches
et autant de branches que l'on veut
simulé de choix possible d'accord vous
comprenez que le nombre de branches à
peu d'importance ici puisque ceux ci
celles ci sont juste des constructions
ou psychique scientifique théorique pour
pouvoir essayer de se représenter les
divers me possible qui résulterait de
mes choix d'aujourd'hui donc imaginons
que moi asap instant donné
j'ai un choix à faire un choix de
carrière le choix d'un pays où j'ai
envie de m'installer le choix d'un
projet personnel et je vais essayé de
modéliser l'impact de mes choix
et bien si je joue prend le choix hein
je me retrouve dans le monde un choix de
deux le choix de rendre montre ce soit
trois mondes possibles qui découlent de
mon choix ici à l'instant zéro mais on
voit que la mécanique est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus complexe puisque
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
ma vie mon parcours de vie et donc les
monde de demain ne sont pas uniquement
influencé par mes choix mais par nos
choix à tous d'accord donc dans cette
mécanique s'amplifier on fait
l'hypothèse que seuls mes choix impact
ma vie du moins j'examine l'impact
marginal de mon choix - sur le sur le
futur de monde possible
une étape deux étapes trois étapes et on
voit que à partir d'un choix tout simple
à une étape donné on peut arriver à une
complexité inouïe d'accord donc la
mécanique conséquent ciel qui produit
des mondes différents dans le futur
d'accord elle se base sur des étapes de
proche en proche qui décision après
décision après décision fait à partir de
décisions élémentaires des modalités et
des possibilités d'une complexité
infinie d'accord alors maintenant on
fait pause et on imagine que on est dans
retour vers le futur
voyez avec le docteur et ainsi de suite
donc il était là et il se rend compte
qu'il a fait une erreur mais il est dans
le futur et donc il a envie de retourner
en marche arrière quelques qui fait et
bien il fait ceci il prend juste un peu
de recul il comprend que en marche avant
mes choix d'aujourd'hui produisent et
conditionne ma vie de demain mais que si
je prend suffisamment de recul et bien
je peux me retrouver
dans cette situation et j'inverse monde
en d'autres termes une logique inverse
ça consiste à formuler les choix de la
manière suivante si je me projette dans
un an
dans dix ans dans 100 ans dans mille ans
quelle est la vie que j'ai envie d'avoir
quel est le monde telles que je les
rêverait telle qu'elle est calé le monde
tel que je le voudrais
d'accord et si j'ai envie d'être dans ce
monde dans 20 ans ou dans 30 ans
qu'est ce que je dois faire l'année
d'avant pour pouvoir atteindre ce
résultat
et qu'est ce que je dois faire l'année
d'avant et qu'est ce que je dois faire
l'année d'avant et donc dans quelle
situation je devais être aujourd'hui
en d'autres termes partir de la fin et
de l'espérance de nos vies c'est le
meilleur moyen de reprendre le contrôle
et d'essayer de comprendre quels choix
je dois faire aujourd'hui pour que ces
mondes soit possible pour que j'ai une
chance de me retrouver dans ce monde là
dans dix ans et dans vingt ans quand on
parlait un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui du
besoin de reprendre en main l'éducation
de comprendre qu' on doit concevoir on
doit espérer un monde avec plus de
bienveillance de comprendre que
l'exclusion n'est pas une fatalité de
comprendre que la somme des souffrances
et la somme des difficultés de nos vies
ne nous détermine pas quand on dit tout
ça qu'est ce qu'on est en train de dire
en filigrane on a enfin de dire qu'en
tant qu'être humain on a une capacité à
rêver et on a une capacité à transformer
ses rêves au projet d'accord et ça c'est
peut-être quelque chose qui fait de nous
des créatures uniques la capacité
quelles que soient nos épreuves quelles
que soient nos souffrances à ne jamais
perdre espoir
donc pour revenir à l'anecdote du début
je ne suis pas la somme des souffrances
que j'ai vécu ce sont des expériences au
bout du compte je ne veux rien renier de
mon passé mais je ne veux rien non plus
renier de mon futur
ce n'est pas l'histoire que je porte sur
le dos c'est l'histoire qui donne des
ailes à mon futur
merci